there's a blockbuster report out from
The Associated Press which says that
there are immigrant US military recruits
and reservists who enlisted with the
promise of this path to citizenship who
are being quietly but abruptly and in
some cases without even an explanation
discharged short of meeting the
requirement to obtain that citizenship
so if this sounds foreign to you
a lot of people don't know that this
exists I actually know an Italian guy
who did it where if you have legal
status in the United States before
enlisting like not if you're here just
visiting but if you're here on a student
visa and by visiting I mean not if
you're just visiting New York for a week
right you're here on a student visa if
you have other legal status in the u.s.
you can enlist in the military you then
are required to get an honorable service
designation and you are then allowed to
be naturalized as an American citizen
and the idea behind it is pretty clear
which is that if you choose to join the
American military if you choose to fight
for the United States then you get
citizenship it's not that controversial
it's a way to earn citizenship and some
of these immigrant service members are
in the middle of the process and they're
being discharged without even being told
why some others have been told that they
represent security risks because they
have relatives in other countries the
Pentagon has been asked for comment they
are not commenting as of right now the
Army has been asked for comment they are
not saying anything about it at this
time and hopefully we'll get to the
bottom of this but the trend is clear
and the trend is that the same
anti-immigrant forces who forget that
this country was built on immigrants
seem to also be forgetting that the US
Army too was built on immigrants
immigrants have been in the US Army
since 1775 immigrants in the American
military are part of why the United
States ultimately won the Revolutionary
War and won independence but it's almost
like who am I talking to right most of
the people that are listening to me say
this know this and if you don't or you
don't care then I'm not going to
convince you anyway
and so really I think the conversation
needs to be focused on the reality that
this is a cruel it's cruel for no reason
but it's also counterproductive why
would we choose to kick people out of
the United States by virtue of kicking
them out of the army or other branches
of the military short of obtaining
citizenship why would we do that when
they have chosen to join the American
military and make that sacrifice
I thought those according to Trump were
the immigrants we did want well maybe
not if they're not white and from Norway
I don't know I want nothing to do with
military service myself and the reason
that I was never drafted the reason we
don't have a draft is because there are
people who are willing to volunteer why
would we kick those people out if
they're willing to volunteer yeah I mean
this sounds like it's not just
anti-illegal immigration it's
anti-immigration we're the publicans
claim that they're not and it's also
anti military in a sense because you're
discouraging people from enlisting right
if you are here on legal status you join
the military expecting to get
citizenship and all of a sudden that's
taken away from you and you're kicked
out of the military why would you want
to do that in the first place why would
another person sign up for that people
aren't exactly breaking down the doors
to join the military I think is the
point that Pat is making recruiting has
been troubled for a long time now not so
troubled that we need a draft but
troubled enough that recruiting is an
ongoing concern for the military we're
now kicking out willing recruits and the
lawsuits are starting we have no idea
where it will end up we have no idea
what position the Trump administration
will ultimately take on this if any and
this is starting to go beyond just an
indifference to immigrants or a
hostility to immigrants this military
policy which again we still not actually
gotten an explanation for what is going
on and why it's going on and who's
directing it this is starting to take
the shape of a proactive plan to cleanse
the institutions of our country of
non-white immigrants period starting
with vulnerable people like those who
join the military as part of this
program to obtain obtained citizenship
how far will it go sadly it's probably
going to go quite a bit further than it
has so far I don't think that this
even close to the end of what we will
see under this administration unless we
put a stop to it at least partially in
November by actually going out and
voting